hello everybody my name is markiplier
now I'm a big dumb stupid idiot because
if I did just walk forward a few steps I
would have realized that this isn't the
same place I was before this is totally
different this is actually a new
location and going through the showers
got me to here so anyway I'm dumb and
when I say I don't really mean I'm dumb
for those who you actually like what are
you doing to my dead body
oh crap that was my first oh well that
would have been helpful to see instead
of being mashed to death and then have
horrible stuff done to my dead body I
would have liked to have seen that vent
open up that would have been fantastic
alright anyway instead of a [ __ ]
alright so what am I doing here I need
to give me a heart attack I really
didn't expect to turn around and see
them there and I'm in a pile of dead
body parts fantastic
oh my luck is an enormous ly good crow D
that's kind of like weird oh I got I
mean the graphics are so good in this
game that I could see every detail of
everything there I don't like to have to
go out oh wait a minute wait a minute oh
these are jail cells that I was just in
know this block see I was in block D
before I remember but that probably
means that there still might be
something around here okay let me just
go like I did before and open any of the
every of the doors here to try to find
something or at least try I don't know
it seems like if there's a door that's
open to belittle say that I can open it
like
[Music]
okay I don't think he's out there I
think he was just patrolling on a level
up and I got kind of startled or not
where is is that him ah damn oh don't
come in here
oh whoa speaking quietly you're big
ain't you
you're a big boy you know when I thought
he was I really thought when he was
gonna grab me before that he was gonna
like pick me up and rip me in half which
would have been totally cool totally
cool okay where am I now where am I now
can I get out there probably not okay no
I cannot okay does this go
I don't think he knows and I'm here up
here can I jump over here yep no how
about I don't don't follow me I'm a
ghost
you're crazy insane you shouldn't be
able to have coherent thought maybe
that's a problem because some psychopath
like that guy you don't see anything
no no no no no squeeze squeeze squeeze
little piggy no no little piggy go to
market little piggy it you're home ha ha
got you beat
okay so those are locked up I'm in Block
C I see a little gap can I get in there
not okay no time to waste gotta go what
happened I didn't oh hi
are you doing you look good there you
look good you uh need anything glass of
water
snack doing okay you're probably just
hiding from the big burly guy right okay
have fun
all right wait is this the way oh this
is where that guy got his head ripped
off good good cuz I want to see this
what what what do you need to tell me
what what your yeah I'm your friend
buddy I'm so much your friend oh my god
oh you're weird get away I got I ain't
got an itch it's so weird get away from
me
you're so weird oh you're so weird oh oh
you're so weird
oh you're weird why are you weird why
are you worried oh you're so weird
oh you're weird weird weird oh oh he's
so strange it's just walking that's all
he's doing it's just walking it's so
weird
what do I need is that a keycard is
that's a playing card Oh get away from
me oh you're so strange oh you're so
strange Oh what do I do what am i doing
what am i doing what am i doing just
tell me what I'm doing I don't know what
I'm doing am i trying to find something
am i trying to find something oh you're
weird you're weird you're weird there's
got to be there's got to be something in
here that I need to find right somebody
need to find that guys like the
creepiest thing I've seen in this place
and all he's doing is just walking
around he's really strange
you're not even scary compared to him
okay aha here we go no no wait that's
just a battery dammit
yeah I'm your friend I'm your friend
buddy I'm so your friend it's got to be
something in these cells that I need I
mean why else would I
I mean Wyatt why else would I do the
thing yeah yeah it's it's buddy buddy
buddy buddy buddy buddy buddy buddy
buddy buddy can open that one what am I
supposed to do I might be it's supposed
to be here is there something that I
need it doesn't look like there's
anything that I actually need here I
would have thought that this guy maybe
this was like a security guy and they
needed to get something from him what
about that it looks important
I guess it's my objective find an
alternate path to the showers Oh get
away okay whatever you know what
whatever I'm out of here
I can't open this just a roomful of that
weirdo and then this guy here it's gotta
be something in there there's got to be
something in there maybe there's like
some objects maybe I can climb up can I
climb up yeah there we go okay that
should have been obvious I'm the total
idiot
yeah yeah oh you're so funny
five not can you knock can you not can
you not how about you go over the edge
I'm gonna send you flying over there
woosh goodbye have fun with that guy
okay hi okay definitely be on the
lookout for guys sitting in chairs okay
buddy don't push me
don't push me buddy don't push me buddy
oh there we go I made it
okay got something all right we got
another witness here then remember there
was a guy that was on the toilet where
he was dead that guy's very dead he
tried to oh no he's not dead it's just a
lot of blood what happened here it's
just a bucket of blood nut not dead guy
all right so this guy's a witness but
he's not dead anyway the guy in the
toilet remember okay
Rudolf gee where Nicky that's the guy
that died passed away doing the work he
loved February 28 2009 he was born in
1918 Munich Germany it said he died 10
years ago so this is set in 2019
mathematic and scientific community for
a paper written were thoroughly
computing pioneer Alan Turing after a
cloudy history with the German war
effort he have a great to the United
States in 1949 with a visa from the
State Department several decades of
government research later in Los Alamos
led to New Mexico where dr. Wernicke
retired to pursue his landscape
photography and care for his cats he
came to Colorado shortly after the turn
of the millennium to pursue a charitable
work for the Murkoff corporation a
statement from the company of dolls
calls dr. Wernicke Wernick a true
humanitarian with a generous spirit he
leaves no survivors that seems rather
final he left no survivors no kidding
his dr. Wernicke the high what you say
to me would you say to me mate oh I'll
deck you one
is he the will debar or the wandered
luster the the spirit thing no guy your
dick wouldn't I just do that the first
time okay so I'm in here the crawl
through here are you dead or alive yeah
run away I'm scary I'm a big scary
monster I almost shot anything in there
no his hiding spots and then follow the
blood I think down there maybe there's a
battery or something over here that I
can claim although I've got plenty of
batteries but yep there's another one
got it alright
super genius markiplier and work here
I've done here alright this is this area
I saw through that window there that I
was trying to get to in the last part
there's a lot of blood it seems to be
just in general there's a lot of blood
ok the word walrider walrider that was
it it's all over this place Murkoff was
running an experiment here called
project walrider but the patient's
talking about walrider like it's a
physical presence a spirited demon
something they found in the mountain I'd
shock it up to schizophrenic delusion
but I just saw something maybe maybe it
was a glitch in the camera or maybe this
place is getting to me did you guys see
something I didn't see anything go back
a little bit see if you saw something
write in the comments it'd be something
like favorite and subscribe if you saw
something ok I remember seeing that
symbol on the floor when those soldiers
were getting killed when the priests
maybe look in the camera in the last
part I don't know if that symbol means
wall right or something but seems to be
in a lot of places
oh good I'm in the shower now I just
need those two naked guys having that
big burly man okay so I saw one of the
patients in here come through this holy
ground I'm hoping that it leads me to
the exit but I have a feeling that it
won't because this place wants to kill
me dead everything about this place
wants me dead
well except the priest he wants me to
see something don't know why though I'm
guessing that the priest is someone who
worked in this facility but originally
but originally did not go super barkos
psycho crazy or no he did go super Bonko
psycho crazy and that's what whoa whoa
okay I was wondering what's going on all
right anyway I don't I'm not gonna make
any crazy theories just yet I'm just
gonna play the game try to find my way
out okay all right
in the sewers love it what would a
horror game be without a sewers level
yeah how do I get out of here
oh hi are you dad that you better be
dead you're actually dead okay you may
be the guy that I saw come down here but
what killed you
Oh crawl into a tiny space perfect
exactly what I wanted to do okay all
right
what was that what was that that's like
a tail what's that what was that was
that the wall writer okay squeeze
through the little gap a little piggy
I'm like paranoid that that's gonna
happen now that was very well done in
the beginning I don't think I don't know
if I mentioned that today
stop doing that whenever a new objective
comes up I've got the volume way turned
up okay so a female war drain prison
block war drain okay am I going to see
the female psycho bonkers crazy
prisoners now
okay so lower Junction down there but it
seems to be flooded I doubt that I want
to swim in sewage nonetheless epic dodge
epic Doge there we go oh no this is also
one of those dead end things oh he got
me okay over here
all right here we go come at me bro let
me Bora what you got what you got you
got nothing
oh no my batteries I'm about to die
squeeze through the gaff go go go go go
little piggy little piggy little piggy
little piggy yeah what now yeah okay
female drink what that you make it seem
like that's gonna drain all the females
what does that even mean I guess this is
gonna drain the water so that I can down
that go down to the lower Junction to be
able to get to the female Ward's all
right that makes sense
I believe it I'm with it I'm hip I'm hip
to that it's happening okay can I go
okay I can go through here which means
that this is where I wanted to run but
it was blocked up because it was too
much water hi where'd you come from how
about you go over there can I throw rock
at least amnesia I could throw rocks to
just lick distract the guards you just
kind of lumbering around I could
probably run by you is that my heart I
hear I hear something thumping okay hop
over that you're so agile and nimble oh
look at you okay
just creeping along
okay all right you swap out the
batteries real quick cuz I know I'll
need them okay he's down there I should
be able to go through here to the pipe
and unless I need to go down that way I
don't know maybe I don't need to go to
the lower Junction maybe I need to go
work he's going right now yeah that's
what I need to do okay there must be
another avenue to go oh my god don't do
that man where can only take so much oh
crap oh crap oh crap oh no he's gonna
bash down the door oh you socked me one
right in the goober you got me right in
the gabber oh no oh no I think I can
make it I can make it oh ouch unless
you're like I'll Drive your way down
this sewer pipe okay I got I don't think
I've mentioned it before but the
implementation of the the the night
vision is very well done in this in this
game anyway I think I'm all that time
for this part oh nice nice death there I
think I'm all done for this part so
we'll see what happens in the female
quarter next so thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation for
more videos it I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm in a pilot crap
[Music]
Wow